foreign
this segment we have in the past
discussed the ever-growing epidemic of
crying Baristas you know there's a whole
genre of video now usually posted at
Tick Tock but sometimes Instagram or
Twitter consisting of Starbucks
employees complaining whining or full-on
weeping about the difficulties of their
jobs their list of grievances are many
and varied but they seem to primarily
take issue with the behavior of the
customer specifically the customer
Behavior they despise the most
is that the customer exists
so the act of existing is what they
really don't like they resent the fact
that customers come into the story to
the store and expect them to do things
and when lots of customers have the
nerve to come into the store at one time
they feel especially attacked these
weepy Baristas they prefer if Starbucks
had no customers they would like to get
paid by Starbucks in fact they want to
get paid a lot more by Starbucks
and yet they also want Starbucks to get
much less business or no business at all
pay me more to do less they demand
this is their bargaining strategy
offered to do less work and in exchange
for that concession
request more money
now at some Starbucks locations across
the country Baristas have unionized
around these demands there's a growing
organized labor movement at Starbucks as
of the beginning of October over 300
locations had held Union elections
purely by coincidence I'm sure some of
the unionized stores were subsequently
closed down by corporate headquarters so
they unionized and then Starbucks says
never mind you're closed union members
allege that this was an act of
retaliation Starbucks corporate denies
the claim I have no opinion either way
personally
um I mean I don't know
all I know all that I'll say personally
is that it is as always
greatly enjoyable to watch a woke
Corporation get eaten alive by its own
woke employees
and yet I must admit that my
satisfaction is impeded somewhat
by the realization that the Starbucks
drama is not playing out on some distant
planet
where I can simply watch it unfold
through a telescope and laugh and then
go about my day on the contrary this is
all happening right here on this planet
in a country that I must share with
those involved
that's what makes it in the end less
funny and a bit more terrifying
especially when you consider videos like
this one which just went viral over the
weekend watch
people wonder why we need a union at
Starbucks and I
am literally about to quit like I I
don't know if I'm gonna do it but like I
really want to I almost walked out today
and I'm crying in the background right
now and I must cut on the floor it's
just
like a full-time student I get scheduled
for 25 hours a week and then on weekends
they scheduled me the entire day open to
close up on the schedule for eight and a
half hours
both Saturday and Sunday I'm like three
and a half hours into my shift there's
so many customers and we have four
people on the floor all day only five
people were put on the schedule and
somebody had to call out and there are
four people running the whole store and
there's so many customers and there's
possibly scheduled five people
we only have 13 people employed at this
store and there's so many customers here
we go
I have to say this Blair Witch Project
reboot is pretty lame uh the Barista
this video is a a union activist who
goes by the name Evan this is also an
Ivy league student apparently which I'm
sure comes as no surprise these days
when you see someone curled up on the
floor trembling in fear muttering
there's so many customers over and over
again like a trauma victim the first
thing you think is that it must be an
Ivy league student but we haven't yet
heard the whole sob story because
there's more to it
let's continue
we don't have Fair scheduling managers
don't care about us our manager was
supposed to come in this weekend and he
took himself off the schedule so he
wouldn't be able to be held accountable
for calling out he just literally poured
on the schedule that he was scheduled on
and put up a new schedule where he
wasn't on the schedule also he couldn't
have even seen that he was scheduled in
the first place because he didn't want
to be held accountable for not wanting
to come in
they don't want to help us
we need a union because this can't
happen this can't happen we need Fair
scheduling we need managers to hold
themselves accountable for helping their
workers they refuse to turn mobile
orders off we need the Liberty to be
able to do that because there's so many
mobile orders and I need to get through
all of them and then people are yelling
at me because I don't have their orders
ready because they don't know what to do
and the customer was misgendering me
today like really badly I didn't have
their order ready and so they were just
like totally talking on each other and
they're like she's clearly incompetent I
have a full mustache and beard
foreign
accommodations for being neurodivergent
I don't
I can't like people get out of me facing
my sick time I don't even know what to
do anymore
I only got my Woods up with this job
I really am
okay a few things here first of all
having a mustache doesn't mean you're
not a woman trust me I know I've I've
been to the women's March second I'm not
going to judge people simply for whining
about their jobs we all whine about our
jobs sometimes but there is a time and
place and context for everything and
whining to the internet while still at
your job during your shift in the middle
of a rush is neither the correct time
nor the correct context nor the correct
place in fact there is no correct time
place or context to air your complaints
about your job publicly if you have a
problem with your schedule talk to your
manager
if you need to vent talk to a friend or
to your mom
or another employee when you're both off
the clock venting to the entire world is
never a good idea
the public can't help you with your
problem we don't know you we aren't your
friend
and our Sympathy for the plight of a
stranger can only be stretched so far
for many of us given that we have real
stresses and real responsibilities in
our lives sympathizing with a grown
adult having a temper tantrum because
she has to work eight hours pouring
coffee is well beyond our emotional
reach
you know I frequently put in 10 or 11
hours a day hour days and then I come
home to help care for my four children
soon to be six
but you're not going to see me huddled
back in the storage closet filming a
teary-eyed selfie video and complaining
about my stresses because I have
self-respect and also because I realize
that there are great many people in this
world who have much harder lives than I
do
I only cry on camera when I'm not giving
a big stuffed animal that I'm owed but
that's totally different
now
this video would not be worth commenting
on if it was just representing a sort of
isolated issue if it was just this one
Barista crying about having to work a
basic eight-hour shift I wouldn't be
worried about the video and if extended
Beyond this one individual but was
relegated only to Starbucks Baristas
we'd still probably be better off
ignoring it but unfortunately this
represents a society-wide problem there
are great many people in this country
who share this person's attitude and to
be clear the Troublesome attitude is not
simply that they don't want to work I
mean nobody really wants to work almost
all of us would take a billion dollars
and spend the rest of our lives on
vacation if that option was presented to
us I have no issue with people who wish
they didn't have to put in the work
I wish for a lot of things that are
unreasonable or impossible
I'm about to have two newborns in my
house again I wish that they're both
gonna sleep soundly through the night
from the moment that they're born
I wish that my kids would keep their
rooms spotlessly clean I wish that we
could walk out the door without having
to look around frantically for
somebody's lost shoe or jacket
I wish for many things
if I ever gain access to a magical genie
I will have a whole laundry list of
wishes ready to go but until that day
arrives
I accept that things are not exactly how
I want them to be and I carry on with my
life and I fulfill my responsibilities
anyway this is the key to adulthood
in fact this is adulthood
it is what being an adult is all about
you must develop the ability to function
and thrive in environments that are not
specifically set up to satisfy your
every desire and whim
you must be able to cope with
frustration and succeed in spite of it
and through it being an adult in the
real world is to be constantly thrust
into situations where things are not
going exactly how you want them to go
and there's more stress than you would
like
and yet carrying on anyway and finding a
way to turn even unfortunate
circumstances to your advantage in
pursuit of your goals
the problem is that we've built a
society filled with people who cannot
handle any amount of frustration at all
they can't carry on let alone Thrive
they collapse and they melt into a
puddle
and rather than than converting
frustration into opportunity which is
what successful people do
they look to convert everything into
pity
because that's the only currency they're
interested in collecting
and the fundamental issue is that while
while nobody wants to work
these people actually think that they
shouldn't have to they don't just wish
for the magical genie they think that
the world owes it to them
and when the world doesn't give them
what they believe they're owed they only
cave into themselves even farther
feeling not only sorry for themselves
but also aggrieved
as though the very realities of human
existence are an attack on them
personally
you cannot function as an adult this way
and if too many people in a society have
this attitude soon Society can no longer
function
that's what we're facing now
and it's why I must say to Evan the ivy
league barista
crying in the storage room
you are today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]